افاد مراسل الجزيره باستشهاد عشره فلسطيني
فلسطينيين اذا واصابه عشرات وجراء القصف
الاسرائيلي المتواصل على خان يونس منذ
صباح هذا اليوم وشهدت المدينه غارات جويه
وقصفاً
كما افاد مراسلنا ان غارات اسرائيليه دمرت
منازل سكنيه في منطقه معن شرق خان يونس من
جهه اخرى قال الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ان
انقطاع الاتصالات المستمر في القطاع تسبب
في تاخر عمليات الاستجابه الطارئه للمرضى
والجرحى من مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس مراسل
الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي مؤمن رحب بك متابعتك
للاوضاع اذا من داخل
القطاع نعم سفيان قبل قليل وصل الى
المستشفى الاوروبي في خان يونس جثمان شهيد
وعدد من الاصابات نتيجه قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف مجموعه من المواطنين شرقيه خان
يونس ليرتفع عدد الشهداء منذ ساعات الصباح
وحتى هذه اللحظه في مدينه خانيونس لوحدها
نتيجه تواصل القصف والغارات الاسرائيليه
الى 11 شهيدا الى جانب عشرات الجرحى الذين
يصلون تباعا الى مستشفى ناصر وايضا الى
المستشفى الاوروبي قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تعمد منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر
وحتى هذه اللحظه على تفجير ونسف عدد من
الاحياء السكنيه والمربعات السكنيه في عدد
من المناطق شرقي مدينه خانيونس تحديدا في
منطقتي بني سهيله وايضا منطقه معم هاتان
المنطقتان تشهد اشتباكات ضاريه منذ يوم
امس بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قوات الاحتلال تعمد
الى شن عبر الطائرات الحربيه شن غارات
جويه كثيفه وتنفيذ احزمه ناريه تدمر
خلالها مربعات سكنيه باعم باكملها كما
رصدت عدسات الكاميرا التي وثقت تصاعد
اعمده كثيفه من الدخان نتيجه الغارات التي
تستهدف هذه المربعات السكنيه في شرق مدينه
خان يونس وتنسف خلالها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه منازل المواطنين التي نزحوا
منها منذ بدايه العمليه البريه
الاسرائيليه تحديدا في المنطقه الجنوبيه
والتي بدات من شرق مدينه خانيونس ايضا
الاشتباكات لازالت متواصله في محيط كليه
العلوم والتكنولوجيا وايضا في محيط مقر
الجامعه الاسلاميه الفرع الجنوب في منطقه
معم بالاضافه الى محيط سوق الحب في منطقه
البلد وسط مدينه خانيونس نسمع دوي
انفجارات واشتباكات الى جانب القصف
المدفعي الاسرائيلي الذي لا يتوقف على
مختلف المناطق عدد من المواطنين منذ ساعات
الصباح يحاولون الوصول الى مناطق في شرق
خانيونس انسحبت منها اليات ودبابات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الا ان المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه والطائرات المسيره
الاسرائيليه تقصف وتستهدف هؤلاء المواطنين
ما يؤدي الى ارتقاء عدد من الشهداء من
الصعوب بمكان على سيارات الاسعاف وحتى على
المدنيين الذين يستخدمون وسائل نقل بدائيه
الوصول الى تلك المناطق لانتشال جثامين
الشهداء الحديث عن عدد من الشهداء والجرحى
في تلك المناطق يصعب على الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني او طواقم الاسعاف التابعه
لوزاره الصحه الوصول اليها لوجود لعدم
وجود اي تنسيق من خلال الصليب الاحمر
وايضا لتدمير كافه الطرق المؤديه الى تلك
المناطق ايضا الغارات الج الجويه
الاسرائيليه والقصف المدفعي استهدف عدد من
منازل المواطنين في منطقه قيزان النجار
وجوره اللوت وبطن السميم بالاضافه الى
منطقه معن وايضا في منطقه الزنه استهدفت
طائره مسيره اسرائيليه عدد من المواطنين
وايضا القصف المدفع الذي يستهدف محيط مجمع
مدارس العوده في منطقه عبسان الكبيره ما
ادى الى ارتقاء شهداء وايضا جرحى في صفوف
النازحين داخل هذه المدارس سنتحدث عن 6000
نازح لا تستطيع طواقم الاسعاف ولا حتى
طواقم الصليب الاحمر الوصول اليهم لانقاذ
حياه الجرحى منهم نتيجه شضايا المدفعيه
والصواريخ الاسرائيليه التي تتساقط في
محيط مجمع مدارس العوده في عبسم الكبيره
ايضا الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
استهدفت مجموعه من المواطنين غرب مدينه
رفح ما ادى الى ارتقاء امراه شهيده وايضا
طفله بالاضافه الى وصول تسعه من الاصابات
الى مستشفى ابوو يوسف صف النجار في مدينه
رفح عدد من هؤلاء من هذه الاصابات جروحها
خطيره بحسب المصادر الطبيه ايضا الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه شنت قبل قليل غاره
جويه بعدد من الصواريخ استهدفت منزلا
لعائله الحولي غرب مدينه رفح ما ادى الى
ارتقاء عدد من الشهداء وايضا وصول اصابات
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في مدينه دير
البلح الى جانبي ان الطائرات مسيره
اسرائيليه من نوع كواد كابتر تستهدف
المواطنين الذين كانوا يمرون من خلال
المدخل الشرقي لمخيم النصيرات ما ادى الى
وقوع اصابات وايضا القصف المدفعي للمناطق
التي انسحبت منها قوات الاحتلال من داخل
مخيم المغازي تستهدفها دبابات جيش
الاحتلال بعدد من القذائف الصاروخيه الى
جانب الاشتباكات المتواصله والمواجهات
المسلحه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال في الاطراف الشرقيه والشماليه من
مخيم البريج شكرا جزيلا لك مؤمن الشرافي